taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right folks welcome to
t-a-s-t-e butts Joe deros here with
taste buds podcast Sal vulcano not with
us today
uh but we do have
some wonderful guests
two dear friends of mine Sarah talamach
yes Katie Hannigan thank you thank you
this is where we find out if you know
our last names
I can't believe I've known Sarah for
I've known Sarah longer than I've known
you but I've known Sarah for probably 15
years at this point and I can't believe
I still have anxiety when I say your
last name but you know what though I let
people roll with it they can say
whatever they want and I don't really
get that offended because I'm just used
to it it's a tough last name yeah but
it's not super tough but for some reason
it trips people up and I also feel like
having a name like that always puts me
in the whole of a friendship because
automatically I'm like well actually
it's talamage and then I'm already
correcting you right off so I said it
wrong I said tolomash well you stumbled
and but your stumble was pretty much
correct it was Charming it was just
chocolate it was easy mine's easy but I
people will still kind of get confused
you know ham ham again
Hennigan because it's like in the
category of Irish names where they all
sound exactly oh Hannigan oh Harrigan
it's like it's just a bunch of people
that came over on a boat well it's funny
there's I'm a big horror movie fan
and there's a new
Stephen King's Story adaptation
that's on Netflix that's not very good
but it's called Mr harrigan's phone and
the story is only about two years old it
was a newer story that they adapted very
quickly but I had the book too and until
I until I saw it until I watched the
movie
I thought it was Mr harrigan's phone I
mean I'm sorry I thought it was Mr
Hannigan's phone it's Mr harrigan's
phone because of what you're saying yeah
so I was watching the movie and I was
like wait a minute it's been Harrigan
for two years
is the scotch one
Seinfeld yeah yeah I dated a guy who had
my same last name but he spelled it
differently so we convinced each other
that it wasn't incest
wow why take the excitement out of the
relationship hang on to something you
saved that for five years in you go
let's start pretending that it is the
same lesson yeah honey I got you
ancestry.com a little fire back into
this
uh we were talking just before we
started and I I always feel like it's
it's sort of half rude to do this
but we all do it with podcasts you go
save it save it save it save it yes I
feel like you're telling your guests
just showed up to shut up but that's not
what it is you're like I don't want to
waste the good convo yes yes but you
were saying how good you felt because
you just canceled a spot yeah you had
tonight which I
can't tell you how much I relate to it
yeah because like you're because I think
during covet I came out of the mindset
of like I got to do less spots or choose
my spots wisely yeah and uh because it
doesn't give me enough time to do the
other things that I want to do and then
I don't feel like the spot was that
beneficial you don't realize how much
energy you're spending like getting
yourself downtown like waiting to go on
going on getting home and then by the
end of it you're like oh I could have
spent three hours writing or just like
[ __ ] around and like recharging
myself or you know yeah any other thing
I I agree I actually was just on
uh Mark I was on we might be drunk Mark
Norman's podcast Mark Norman who your
Eskimo brothers with yeah list exactly
um Eskimo wives yeah but I just I just
was on their podcast and I was and Mark
and Sam Morrell greatly disagreed with
me but I was talking about this and I
was like
I'm a big believer of you hit a point in
comedy where
doing spots it gets to it's for the I
don't see the point after unless you're
working on a new joke or like unless
you're like really intentionally working
on something you do get diminishing
returns I think I think so I think it
becomes very habitual and I think of it
I actually had to talk so Paul Italia
who owns the stand who's also my partner
at my the sandwich shop I have Joey
roses
um we talked about it I said you're not
going to see me around the club for a
while he said why I said because I've
got my new hour where I want it to be
and I work on it on the road I'm not
going to come to your Club just to do a
cash run I'm not doing that dude like
it's not fair to you it's not fair to
your audience for me to come in there
and just trudge through it because it's
money it's it's easy money and I I go
I'm not when I have stuff to work on
again I'll call you guys and I'll come
back through and that's it you know like
yeah and I feel like that's how it
should be but there's a there's a very
like habitual thing with comedians where
it's like no a comic goes out there and
does the shows every single night but
what you just said it's like yeah but at
what cost well people that like write
books you know you write the book and
then they take like five months off and
they go like live in London and have
like coffee and stuff and we just like
do we ever get to like have time off
where we're not like I gotta get to the
top yeah I know I know it's true well
the thing is like I was coming from
Astoria going all the way to Staten
Island and then I'm going back to
Astoria and then I have to go back to
the Lower East Side to bomb in front of
like 25 year olds that won't think I'm
funny because I always bomb there it's
uh yeah I mean it's like I hear you I
hear you uh it's by the way way real I
got distracted because I'm this vain
patent office won't responded to my
tweet
does that patent Oswalt is that left
column mean the right column here the
the tweets on the right there yeah this
is the comments in your Tweet oh I got
it oh look at that
wow what was your original tweet
and I tweeted that actor Bruce Willis
became the first celebrity to sell his
rights to to be a deep fake oh I saw
this but it came out that it was fake
his team came out and said that's not
true that was a deep fake deep deep fake
which means one's one of two things
either it wasn't true or it was and they
were like don't we have to back out of
it yeah that's true yes
anyway Kendra Morris and Pat Oswalt
first two two of the first you gotta
like when you get two verifieds like
that two people who you enjoy and mental
mental yeah health ward wait what does
that say mental heal word that's very
funny mental heal Ward wrote damn Joe
this hit me right in the McLean's that's
very funny
um
so black Crescent Bar responding black
Crescent one of the greatest bars in New
York City and it's right across the
street from Joey roses do a little one
for two for your money two for ones nice
uh anyway best wings in New York at
black Crest oh yum
um but yeah no it's like you're saying
it's like it's like at what cost you're
trading all this it's a lot of energy
for no uh huge outcome and meanwhile now
when you have like the internet you can
post a clip a 10 second clip and it's
gonna get you could get 90 000 views and
it's like well that wouldn't you rather
just do that say something into your
phone how do you feel about that one kid
I forget his name who just shoots
himself in his apartment on a green
screen and dubs in crowds
oh and people read it as real stand up
on Tick Tock and now he's selling
tickets
well there's a lot of he's doing better
than I am yeah I am I'm ready to do it
too I need money there's a lot of I
might I might big quotes around Mike
because I don't know what it means yet
but I got a phone call the other day
about having a discussion with some
people about metaverse stuff ooh wait I
just saw I don't know if this is true
but then they find out they spent
billions of dollars and only found out
like 30 people are using it yeah yeah
something sad like that and it's either
gonna be really the wave of the future
or yeah it's like or a big bust yeah it
just doesn't seem like it like you could
just hang out with people you don't need
to pretend to hang out with other people
like why don't we just go to a bar
instead of going to like a pretend bar I
don't quite well the it's getting into
the world of performance which I don't
quite understand what the differences
between metaverse and Netflix
I record something and stream it and you
want to join like the room
to watch with other people and pretend
like you're there when I recorded it
that's just like Netflix you're doing
your stand up as like a polar bear like
that's your avatar yes yeah sexy old man
I'm not against a I'm not against a
green screen comedy special but I would
want a real audience there yeah but you
could probably this is what I think the
metaverse will be because at one time
have you ever done virtual reality
oh yeah yeah I did the one where you
took the mask and then you you have Fox
arms and you're bouncing from like
mushroom to mushroom and I was like this
world is wonderful I did that too and it
was fun to connect it online and then
have your other friends come and meet
you in this like room you I do feel like
you are kind of interacting with people
I think uh there I think there's
look I think it's like anything I think
there's a healthy way to do it in an
unhealthy way to do it
just like
Twitter unhealthy
ill currently ill yeah just like it's
just a lingering cough I swear I'm not
contagious but I don't care cough in my
mouth I really don't even care at this
point I know I'm done anymore I don't
give a [ __ ] I don't even know why I got
the new booster I don't care anymore I
like being sick at this point I like
being in the house it's so luxurious oh
my God take a bath watch 10 episodes of
the same show in a day
um anyway the um I'd get vaccinated yeah
no there's I guess I have to disclaim it
whenever I joke about it because I don't
want people to attack me online
but no there's like a healthy way in a
healthy way right it's like it's uh you
could you could do you could do Twitter
in a healthy way yeah you can do it in
an unhealthy way most P here's the
problem the metaverse like VR like
anything most people will do it in an
unhealthy way oh I think there's already
been cases of sexual assault in the
metaverse
oh my gosh yeah here's a documentary I
mean you can actually sexually assault
an avatar like a Sim situation can I
teabag somebody in the game yeah yeah oh
so it's not not physically
perhaps demeaned diminished yeah yeah
that is that is that disturbing and it
looks like Mark Zuckerberg is they the
one who did it he's so creepy with his
little face folks Joe DeRosa here from
the taste buds podcast I got live dates
coming up where I'm going to be
performing my new one hour show I Never
Promised You a Rose Garden it's actually
a little more than an hour you get a
little extra for your catch anyway
November 8th for the New York Comedy
Festival in New York New York at the
black cat in New York right next door to
Joey Rose's one show only I am doing a
very Intimate Presentation of I Never
Promised You a Rose Garden uh I will
also be at the come and take it Fest at
the end of November in Houston Texas at
the secret group uh and then December
8th in St Petersburg Florida Coastal
creative live that's the venue on
December 8th we're doing we'll see you
in hell live Pat Walsh and myself my
other pod doing a live show and then on
the 9th and 10th I'll be doing I Never
Promised You a Rose Garden at the same
venue Coastal creative in St Petersburg
Florida January 13th and 14th I'll be in
Austin Texas at the Vulcan come out and
see that we got four shows going on
there and then January 20th and 21st two
shows in Levittown New York a Governor's
Comedy Club all shows and tickets uh and
info and everything all of it's
available at jodorosainfo.com and let's
not forget if you're in New York City
please come see Joey Rose's sandwich
shop and Social Club full bar full
Sandwich Bar full booze
drink have a great
Grace open it at 12 P.M every day come
see us uh we're at 174 Rivington Street
all of the info for the venue Joey roses
is available at joeyrosesnyc.com
also you can order your delivery for
yourself through our website uh
joeyroses nyc.com or through doordash
see out there but here I have a I have a
documentary for you guys it's called
second life it's on Netflix it came out
in like
2010 I think it is uh maybe it's
yeah Life 2.0 this is what it is it's
um yeah the early days of virtual
reality and it kind of goes through the
dysfunction of people that like deeply
lose themselves lose their identities in
this world like this woman leaves her
husband it is so dysfunctional and just
juicy it's it's I just think it's like
the problem is it I I I I I I
uh uh the debate's the wrong term that
sounds too intense but I I conversate
with a friend of mine about this
where he talks about like
his stance is and this is proven it's
you know by by experts the world around
or whatever but like Twitter is just for
instance Twitter is designed in a way to
bring the worst behavior out of you yes
it is because it keeps you online yeah
it really is it's frustrated rewarded
yeah and it's designed to to trigger
things in you so you behave in a way
that is not constructive yeah that's
what it's designed for but
or that's how it's designed my counter
argument to that is always the same
thing well I'm sure it doesn't help but
the problem isn't Twitter the problem is
us anything you give us we use it
incorrectly look in in the United States
at least look at fast food look at the
internet look at voting look at guns
like any single thing you give us that
allow look at Yelp reviews look at
Rotten Tomatoes it any single thing you
give the American public and say the
power is in your hands they completely
misuse it one thousand percent look at
marijuana out like it's everything we
agree with that because I think that
like it it is designed specifically to
exploit people and that's like the big
the big issue with capitalism is this
like it is exploiting the fact that you
know it's like I'm not getting on
Twitter and misusing it you know like
I'm on there like I farted you know I'm
like trying to get a little laugh but
like but but if you're speaking for the
majority yeah majority does but it is
designed to exploit the worst type of
people it's like the same thing with
like YouTube it's like they they
designed it to be like putting you into
like a k-hole of like white supremacy
videos okay and they do make it easier
and they exploit those people that are
just on there for that you know so
you're saying it's it only seems like
the majority because a magnifying glass
is put over this demographic
this smaller demographic of awful people
yes and I have a statistic to back that
up but I can't remember what it is but
just pick it up I'm
Brian Webster I I saw something that
this was a couple years ago where they
did have this thing that came out it was
like it seems like everybody on Twitter
is like reactionary and inflammatory but
actually when you look at who it is it's
a small portion of the people that are
on Twitter doing that stuff and it gets
magnified and Amplified that it looks
like everybody is it looks like that's
what is happening all the time
um well I always that's what I always
say to like when people go like
you know neo-nazis are more vocal than
they've ever been in this country and
it's like everybody is more vocal than
they've ever been yeah yeah and
everybody like every single awful
or or wonderful or Niche or Main Street
whatever tag you want to put on
something that group whether it's
righteous or virtuous or heinous is
louder than they've ever [ __ ] been I
hear more about baked goods than I've
ever heard in my life a witch love it in
my life and there's turmoil and baked
goods too some you know what I mean
yeah because you have to have a story as
a small business person like I survived
cancer
and opens my cupcake shop
what's there is no Joey Rose's story we
gotta make one up folks
[Music]
this time now I have a sandwich shop to
take my mind off of the porn I was
watching no I I don't know I don't have
a what's the tragic the origin story a
man from a ditch in Philly yeah well no
actually there was a very long one that
I told on the Pete home show about how
down I was this is actually a great one
you found out you were adopted adopted
um how'd you find out pigeon toad to an
extent what how'd you find out that was
adopted yeah oh I I ever since I was a
baby I do oh you knew yeah they never
told me I mean they they told me from so
long early on I don't remember I always
wondered if there's like a coming out
for the parents to adopt the people is
it like a I guess for some people I just
got told it seems very you though to be
like a suspicious baby on brand for you
like I think I know these people like
right outside the vagina
that's really funny
I'm trying to so I'm trying to write a a
show idea about a child
we've talked about it on here but a
child who because I lived near a ditch
when I was a kid and I was depressed not
staring at the dash so I'm trying to
write a show idea about that but can I
use the thing where he's suspicious that
he might be adopted oh my god of course
I knew I was never yeah
get Mommy's bath pearls
that kind of sounded like my mom in a
weird way so what do you think I'm an
actor are you doing like Matilda but you
I never saw Matilda you never saw
Matilda so psychological abuse
she's got a pig nose right so it is it's
just about me is it because of the girl
with the pig nose where's like magic
powers do you have magic power that'd be
no no no he just he just I don't want to
say too much but okay yeah what kind of
ditch concrete or grass yeah it was
grass it was grass so like a yeah yeah
that's nature it was breathing yeah
um
yeah it's funny I mentioned it to my dad
the other day I was because I went back
and visited it did you you put up the
video right yeah we watched it back yeah
and I was like Dad I went back to the
ditch and he was like remember the
muskrats and I was like no but the
muskrats so there's nature
yeah it was an interesting uh it was an
interesting anyway in any case let's get
into food stuff we're talking about real
heavy [ __ ] here what do we got uh on the
food front in food news McDonald's is
going to start sending these adults
selling these adult happy meals
that come with nostalgic toys people
have messaged me about this I talk about
McDonald's a lot on this show and how
it's great I walk by one every night and
I'm amazed that I don't stop in there
every day and I'm so proud of myself oh
it's so hard not to go the smells are
coming out I like the Buns you know
what's good finally help me get off
McDonald's was the um the ticket size oh
the tick tocks of them looking at the
Nuggets under the microscope and seeing
all the micro Plastics in it it's a lot
won't stop me there's none in the city I
gotta tell you though this is wild
so I had to change my diet recently for
health reasons a doctor told you yeah
doctor was like
yeah stop [ __ ] around yeah it's time
it's it's nerve-wracking when your
doctor says you you've never seen me
alarm before have you it's like no and
he was like so then listen to me uh it
wasn't a good feeling yeah
anyway I won't get too into that but but
I so I started eating a lot more
meatless meals okay which which have
included and by the way
I'm gonna say this
don't send comments about the fake me I
don't care I don't want to hear why it's
worse
I I got to get through this right now so
leave me alone but I had to cut back on
cholesterol because people will be like
you know fake needed maybe I'd get back
yeah I know destroying third world
countries because of the factories yes
I had to cut out one of the main issues
was cholesterol so I started eating like
fake meat because it has no cholesterol
and it's significantly lower in fat than
you know regular meat
you have to watch sodium counts and I I
get it
get
it
but I I have been eating the Beyond
chicken tenders and they are
Beyond they're amazing they're industry
yeah from chicken tenders and I was like
these are as good as McDonald's chicken
McDonald's which made me realize my God
chicken nuggets truly never had chicken
in them yeah no like this concoction
they've made for fake meat like it's
it's chicken McNuggets except without
the cholesterol and a lower fat count
and probably no microplastics in those
two I would think not I don't think
they're putting them in there yeah so
there's a there's a version of it you
can eat now I feel like we're I'm not
saying you could eat these every day but
like you could eat them and not feel
terrible about yourself great that's
great I mean that's what it is about
like when you're getting older it's just
like realizing that there are other
healthy alternatives that you can have
McDonald's like once in a while and then
you have your chicken nuggets everything
they have like the impossible Burger I
gotta tell you a lot of yeah a lot of
times Burgers now over these last few
weeks that I've been doing this I eat a
veggie burger
I don't put cheese on it and I put sugar
I I put diet ketchup because the diet
Hinds to me I can't tell the difference
yeah it's got some [ __ ] sugar
substitute in it but a chemical ketchup
mustard tomato onion and pickles on it
and it hits the it hits the mark yeah
and I don't feel sick after yeah yeah I
I love a veggie burger I've I've talked
about this on our show before uh the big
leap burger at Quantum Leap in the
village I think it is the most amazing
veggie burger that I've ever had you
have to try it
now I'm going to say to you what I was
yelling at the listeners not to say to
me
but there are fake meat things that I've
had where I'm like oh my God this is
incredible and then you look at it and
I'm like this is so bad for me yeah I
think it is one of those actually
I'm crazy for the impossible Whopper
yeah and the impossible burger patty in
and of itself is fine but when you get
all the other [ __ ] on top of it that you
put on a Whopper yeah in combo with the
impossible Patty you're not doing much
better than a [ __ ] Whopper yes it's
true the big leap Burger does have it
has onion rings and avocado on it so I
don't know if you want to add a pattern
it's so good though like I can't tell
the difference there's chocolate ice
cream on top it tastes the same
the Quantum Leap burger and tell us the
oh there it is the big leap burger oh my
God and they have the most amazing
garlic fries at that place too oh I love
it their salad is good everything there
is so good see if we can get some
Nutrish on the Quantum Leap burger or
the big leap Burger it won't tell you on
um folks let's talk about our sponsor
better help
whoa
better help I could use you today and
you could too folks it's tough to train
your brain to say to stay in problem
solving mode
all right life faces you with challenges
trust me people I'm I'm faced with them
now I got the challenges on the table in
front of me not literally but
figuratively they're in front of me
people and it's tough to keep that brain
in the right Zone all right now I got
initially inspired to to try therapy
and this is years and years and years
and years ago
uh because I
wanted to be able to compartmentalize my
thoughts a little bit better how to how
to separate the anxiety
from the uh uh problem solving as we
already said uh how to separate problem
solving from being motivated to do
certain things from your goals and the
goals you're setting uh etc etc etc all
of these things can start to bleed
together in my experience and then what
you end up with is a snowball of
something you can't decipher a friend of
mine recently equated
figuring out the the issues that you
have and solving them one by one it's
like organizing a closet you know if you
look at the closet and the closet's a
mess you say where am I going to do and
I don't have anywhere to put all this
stuff while I try to organize a class
and you just get so overwhelmed but if
you just take one piece out at a time
and start to work on it section by
section before you know it you have an
organized closet and that's what Better
Health helps you do it helps organize
this closet and folks this is a messy
closet okay so if you're thinking about
giving therapy a try better help is a
great option it's convenient it's
accessible it's affordable and it's
entirely online trust me folks I've used
it it's great uh when you want to be a
better Problem Solver therapy can get
you there so you're going to visit
betterhelp
dot com slash taste buds today to get 10
off your first month that's better
help.com taste buds better
help.com taste buds guys you asked for
it for so long we finally got it merch
is on sale right now uh we really talk
about it but I want to start pushing it
because we have a really cool designs
that Joe and I made up ourselves and
it's the limited run so whatever is on
sale now the second is sold out it's not
coming back it's available right now uh
in the links on these videos or at our
website savocanocomedy.com Joe
derosainfo.com that's tastebuds merch I
also have solo merch uh up there as well
uh and uh so check all of it out and uh
and and buy some merch tweeted us the
merch and we will retweet you we'll
repost you on Instagram we want to see
which ones you guys are liking and we
want to see the merch out in the wild
God I love that place I want to go there
today this is kind of funny man like
people aren't if you notice restaurants
the nutrition facts aren't there anymore
I kind of don't want them on there yeah
I don't want to go and count
yeah
I want to eat and enjoy myself yeah like
we went to Cheesecake Factory and it was
just like oh I guess I'm eating the
entire food that I need for the weekend
right now and do I need to know that
that sucker for my mental health let me
just have my weird egg rolls my
Southwestern Fusion egg rolls I came out
to like Escape I don't need to be in the
beach
yeah nothing pimp right no nothing yeah
remember when it was like if your
restaurant didn't have the things up it
was like what are you doing you monsters
I feel like it's it was a and now it's a
thing outside of New York still but in
New York it's like not the law it's just
like whatever because we're like we're
walking we're fine Bloomberg got in
trouble because he was trying to do
social medicine and then that's why I
was like you can only have one soda or
only like 16 ounces of coke and people
were like how dare you but then you're
like well that's what happens when
you're trying to socialize
medicine is like hey guys but you can't
be diabetic when I'm trying to help all
y'all this goes back to what I was
saying earlier about the American
culture this actually I think counter is
a Counterpoint though to what you said
the other I've been to other countries
as we all have other countries have soda
available they have McDonald's available
and you look at the weight difference
and the and not even the weight
difference the health difference between
here and other places and it's like they
don't they have soda but they don't
drink 64 ounces of it yeah it's cultural
like Europeans have like a more slim
culture but they also don't put a ton of
[ __ ] in their food like we do have the
junk food though and they're just it's
true but do you think England and
Ireland are catching up with our fatties
but but yeah we do have a culturally
like
obese like mindset where it's like the
standard American diet like European
people are like oh my God like we're
having like a little light salad and
some fish and some crackers
a little wine you know like it's very
and eating super slow and like a meal
time is like a whole long thing for them
where they chat and Meanwhile we're just
like shoving a burger into our face
alone before we like race off into the
night to our third job yeah trust me I'm
a thousand percent guilty of it I'm not
I'm not pointing any fingers here the uh
but like you know it's like when you go
overseas and like you see people drink
wine at lunch
and you're like how can you drink wine
and then go back to work I can't do it
because they're like because we have a
glass
and it's meant to compliment the meal
it's not the beginning of the end yes of
canceling yeah I'm canceling everything
yeah if I'm having a glass of wine for
lunch yeah I don't know I'm relapsing
that's okay are you sober uh no Sarah is
oh yeah oh that's right I forgot you
were shopping yeah yeah oh wow how sober
are you I am 13 years holy God yeah
you're a tea totaler tea totally I'm
kind of sober I have like one glass of
wine and then I'm like goodbye okay it's
like let's have a beer I know I'm like
let's be naughty
I wish
I wish I could do that yeah well I got
better at it during the pandemic I just
kind of like was finally taking care of
myself for the first time and I was like
oh I don't even feel like having a drink
or like getting so stoned that I like
don't know who I am
I could use another lockdown
in an order
oh it was really nice actually another
lockdown to kind of get just have time
to focus on diet and getting better my
cooking went through the roof I mean I'd
have sugar for like a month I like my
cooking skills went from like pretty
good and basic to like medium good like
I can make recipes now it's like it's
exciting you're gonna get another walk
down probably dude
290 million dollars worth of radiation
sickness drugs after Putin made serious
threats yeah I saw about that are we
just radiating I love how you guys are
getting the news from Instagram this is
just like Instagram [ __ ] but then
Nancy Pelosi invested in radiation
poisoning oh and they have the inside
trading and they invested in covid stuff
too what a great person
Nancy Pelosi oh yeah yeah why is drug
bleeped out
like everything has to be censored now
or the algorithm Flags it it's crazy
it's just ridiculous demo really yeah
me too I'm done with this place I want
to move away but you're already infected
dude you're an addict everywhere else
you're gonna be like what am I doing I
want to move away I don't want to live
here anymore I'm tired
look at this look at what we're looking
at well this is world this is a world
issue Elon Musk is going to solve it
yeah he's gonna solve it with Twitter
he said he called Putin I'm like for
what what I mean Elon Musk is such a
great example of everything how stupid
our culture is now I'm not saying he
doesn't say problematic things I'm not
saying he doesn't have views I disagree
with whatever but the fact that this guy
is as rich as he is and working on the
[ __ ] he's working on and people are just
like
um past you're like guys I don't know
who you think's gonna do this [ __ ] yeah
he has that entrepreneurial spirit that
you needed to like you know come over
and discover other countries like
William Randolph Hearst was a bastard
but like it's like you need people that
are like like hey guys I'm a billionaire
and I'm gonna kind of think about these
things
effective than the government sometimes
it's wild yeah yeah it's wild like it's
like do you want every I don't know who
people think are gonna crack these Pro
like like you think a podcaster is going
to do it and then if the pot they do and
then but then if the podcaster gets too
big then they're mad at the podcast yeah
yeah would you would you go to Mars Joe
would you do it I could barely cross I
can barely get to Staten Island to do
this show
I would do it but think about the food
up there it's like the freeze-dried ice
cream that's gonna be the first thing to
run out I don't like Halo ice cream and
I feel like that's space food oh the
Halo top yeah it gives me a terrible
stomachache yeah because I eat the
entire thing which they promote that as
like the portion size that's the that's
the main thing it has going for it they
forgot to screamed at us on here about
Halo top does he like it he loves it and
Sal was like I don't like that you have
to let it sit for 15 minutes and Nate
was like they're trying to save lives
they've created a miracle how you have
some patience for guts it does not fill
my god-sized hole up you know what I
mean that feeling of emptiness like or
ice cream will kill that for me for
about an hour yeah I'd rather have just
a normal portion of like Haagen-Dazs and
then be like I'm good yeah like just
stop I developed a um dairy allergy so I
just can't have ice cream at all oh my
God I'm eating too much no foodie cuties
is that like a fake ice cream they're a
little um they're soy ice cream but
they're little ice cream sandwiches and
they're so good uh if you like Beyond
Burger you don't like tofu cuties it's
it any sort of milk
gives me like this were same reaction I
don't know what it is wow like I've
tried oatmeal I've tried almond milk
it's like no it's it's a it's a godsend
oh because I love cheese can you eat
cheese some cheeses I can't some cheeses
I can't but I'm telling you it's a
godsend it God was just like
ice cream's gone bro what about
chocolate cereal I was like wow that
just cut out two aisles of the day yeah
yeah for me chocolate
uh I can eat like dark like really dark
chocolate like I'm talking like 85 cacao
and then why even do it
I ate a piece or two sometimes after
dinner because it helps with digestion
it's good for to bring cholesterol down
yeah but um no again it's a godsend it's
like it's like just the universe being
like bro these foods are off the table
and I was like thank you yeah but kind
of like this cholesterol thing in a
weird way is a godsend it's like it's
just like bro cut out steak except for
twice a month no more pork you know what
I mean like like get rid of no more like
you can't have pizza dude you can't have
fast food anymore like so what are you
eating I ate a lot well so far it's I
try to do as much as I can for myself
but I I I I just try to stick to no
cholesterol foods and things that don't
have a ton of ingredients oh you gotta
get into lentils Joe are you a little
guy I'm bringing beans back into the mix
oh I love it yeah
yeah
hummus lots of guac I don't eat tacos I
just make them with like fake meat or
with turkey yeah get the low sodium mix
like it's just like little stuff like
that like when I was on the road this
weekend
instead of getting like pizza or
whatever after my shows or drinking
uh I just went and I got like I got
salsa and I got corn chips oh love it
and I got like some beans and I just I
just ate that until I was like full and
I put it down like
you know I mean look corn chips aren't
the best thing in the world to eat but
they're a hell of a lot better than
getting like a big mac oh I love corn
chips I love the crunch yeah I love I
actually a lot of times prefer to go to
the grocery store and get snack stuff
like that than to go out to eat
something because I just love like snack
foods I just love it like a meal like
chips and salsa as your dinner like oh
it just feels like a luxurious like
you're 16 and you're like so far this is
my meal like I'm doing whatever I want
my mom's gone chips and guac chips yeah
I agree I agree I thought about this the
other day you know how like you can go
and get a baked good yeah like as your
snack but I want salty snacks why can't
there just be a store that's called
snacks where you can get like a few
fries
[Laughter]
would be
like how a baked like Starbucks it's
quicker I can tell you why I can tell
you no homeless people in there I think
I think it's a cool idea I promise you
the the reason why is because that is
such an unsustainable thing once it's
cooked
you can't reheat that like you can't you
air fry it up again
I'm telling you like like cocktail
weenies are a great example I love
cocktail wings I love them guinea pigs
in a blanket they're done once once
they're cooked yeah that's it get them
while they're getting's good you cannot
reheat those yeah that you know what I
mean but baked goods you can make your
own water all the time that's true
croissants croissant what's the shelf
life on a croissant baked goods only
have like five hours oh no that's why
they have too good to go gone to a
bakery in the afternoon it's crap you
might as well just they're like sand
castles yeah
you're not getting five you could make
the hors d'oeuvres to order you'd have
to do it to order yeah which is deep
frying frozen food [ __ ] really fast I
think it's a good idea why don't you
pursue that I don't have any Capital
Joey Rose's sandwiches and small hors
d'oeuvres
yeah uh yeah maybe you that's why we
asked to come on this podcast we want to
pitch you our business plan you're our
Shark Tank I wish
I wish we had a bigger location at Joey
roses because like stuff like that I
would be like come do a pop-up and you
just have ordered yeah uh I wish we had
a bigger kitchen to do stuff like that
kind of thing like that'd be so cool
what is this pip
21 worst food ideas ever
Crystal Pepsi oh yeah Crystal Pepsi
sucked yeah Oreos is getting out of
hands Oreos oh my God it's it's like
Oreos Mega stuffed yeah like cakes or
Oreos it's like that's that's just a
whoopie pie you're just pretending you
invented whoopie pies can cheeseburger
is disgusting pancake sausage on the
stick by Jimmy Dean was genius I think
that could be come back but rebranded
that was awesome that was like a
breakfast corn dog what you want a corn
dog to taste like and it's easier to go
on the go because your hands aren't
dirty because you got your stick yeah
sweet and savory and that's what I love
the outfit yeah look how good that looks
heading to a meeting
those right
that's for a working mom it's so funny
I'm gonna be in Canada October 14th and
15th Hamilton Toronto we edit a show I'm
going to be in Richmond Virginia and
Hershey Pennsylvania in October
in November I'm going to be in
Knoxville Atlanta and Birmingham where
is the [ __ ] where is this
[ __ ] please no you're fine
you're fine I got it I'm very scared
dude
I'm gonna be in Louisville and
Evansville and then in December I'm in
Florida and California and Florida I'm
in Tampa we ended the second show show
I'm at tall Hard Rock in Orlando the
Crest Theater in Sacramento uh
Jacksonville what's up on that
and see Sacramento San Jose and Santa
Rosa in December everything's on sale
right now on sale volcanocomedy.com
well done well done there you go
Sarah what you were talking about they
have a lot of that in the UK and then
also in like in Ireland and whatever
like like there's like Street Foods yeah
and like there's like like when you go
to their convenience stores they have
like sausage rolls and things that are
very much like Hors d'oeuvish yes
being like I'll take two pigs in a
blanket one egg roll and you put it in a
fancy box and then you go eat it in the
park ew celery jello well oh it's not
that weird because in in Asia like I've
been to China and China Jello gelatin
they use it in all kinds of cities they
probably have like beef broth Jello yeah
or like in the 70s there was a lot of
like jelly Savory salads yeah Jello
salads they do gelatin noodles in China
that are just clear noodles of gelatin
oh glass noodles yeah they mix it in
like a hot sauce yeah so I think I've
had that before and it was good I could
get on board with a lifesaver drink that
sounds I love Lifesavers pineapple that
sounds delicious to me we should get to
the topic we're really
yeah we're never going to get together
we're 45 minutes in and we never started
the
uh look this is the pre-pod yeah folks
today's debate
is in defense of the twinkie we're gonna
do something new here today that's why
we didn't do a poll
or at least I don't think South did a
poll I never told him to
I said no need to do a poll but then he
was texting me poll ideas
so who knows with this kid anymore you
know what I mean he's all over the map
what's what did he say nothing local
okay no poll great
um so we're gonna do something different
here today where basically we're going
to take a food
and here's where I think we could do
this taste buddies without the poll and
sometimes we could do it with the poll
where could just be a yay or an A but a
lot of the times the poll it's you know
you're voting well all the time with
Paul you're voting without hearing the
argument
uh and the argument may or may not
change your vote after you hear it I
don't know but I wanted to try something
where we we do a debate about a food
where we're not necessarily doing a
battle saying this thing is better than
that thing but we're taking a food that
one where more of us loves
uh and then pitting it in debate against
people that don't like that food and
just
basically making this a trial the
twinkie is on trial here today I am in
defense of the twinkie you're probe
Twinkie very much and you guys are harsh
prosecutors pro-choice
[Laughter]
yeah
that's a good thing
about political you made it
Pro choosing to not have a Twinkie I
refer to abortions as Twinkies hahaha
just so it sounds easier when I'm
offering the woman money
sounds more palatable this is for a
Twinkie a case
no uh here's the thing so you got I said
I said to Katie tell me foods that you
and Sarah Love and Hate
and you and you Katie wrote back and one
of the first things in her hate category
was Twinkies and I was like
that's nuts to me like I don't even
understand okay let me just say that
like if a Twinkie was the only thing
around I would eat it but that doesn't
mean that I don't hate them yes I
tolerate them I do hate them but I also
will eat it
so I just want to be clear about that
okay but out of the the you said snack
cakes like the twinkie I don't like
snack cakes in general but I do like
some like donut sticks and oatmeal cream
pies Ding Dongs but which so I mean we
can we can broaden this to the defense
of the snack cake
uh it doesn't have to just be Twinkie
what snack cakes do you dislike and then
we can get into I definitely don't like
Twinkies you said you'd eat them though
but I would eat it that doesn't mean you
that means you like it then
I kind of hate them though I've been
looking at it right now I'm like this is
disgusting mate like banana absolutely
not but I would eat like a regular one
or like if I was starving let's stick to
what you hate about it well anybody want
anything about it you're starving this
is what I hate about the twinkie okay it
we were talking about this on the way
over it I think it this is the corn
syrup in it the lack of natural
ingredients there's no soul it has no
soul it's like you're eating it you're
like okay that was like kind of good it
makes your breath taste bad afterwards
why is it make your breath taste bad
because of the sugar I think it's the
corn syrup but it never gets you to that
place where you're like yes this is so
good I couldn't disagree more Sal and I
excuse me Sal and I are great Defenders
Of The Twinkie
to the point that when we debated snack
cakes on the podcast we had to take
Twinkie off the table because we both
agreed that it is the all-time greatest
of any snack cake there's no way the
Twinkie
I think looks magical
tastes magical when I eat one I want
another one I love when they started
doing I believe they come in a two pack
now I love to start doing that even
talking about it right now all I want to
do is get a Twinkie when I on the way
home and I won't allow myself but what
is it that you what is it that you hate
about the twinkie I think it uh like it
offers it presents itself as if it's
going to hit your dopamine
meaning like it's this is going to bring
joy to my life but I feel like I never
get actual Joy from eating a Twinkie
yeah as much as the other
snack cakes like a Twinkie that was a
fresh Twinkie that was made in a bakery
that day that I would like yeah
I know full cream
I'm I'm a experimenting philosophically
here but like it's the taste of
preservatives that I don't like in snack
cakes and that makes me hate them right
yeah I don't think the cream is actual
cream you don't say I think it's I don't
like Crisco and sugar you guys are
really blowing the lid off of the
twinkie today listen we know it's all
fake
but what about the taste do you not like
I just feel like compared to the other
cakes out there it doesn't do the job
the other cake would you put over the
top I like that cupcake I also I don't
know if this falls in the same category
but they're in the same aisle as the
powdered donuts
donuts I love a powdered donut with milk
ah yeah I'll tell you right now dipping
I'll tell you right now I won't eat a
powdered donut at a donut shop I'll take
even oh my God sugar jelly I won't even
eat oh no I hate such a powder I hate
jelly donuts I hate jelly that's
something you guys might have a problem
with things that are filling I do not
like filling I do not like I don't like
true so much sugar that you don't even
taste any flavors yeah and that's what
the twinkie does it almost numbs you to
the point that you when you're taking a
bite you're like I'm I'm not tasting it
I'm just getting diabetes yeah that's
what I'm tasting I'm tasting my insulin
shutting down I don't think it's worth
the risk
I know the original shelf life of
Twinkies was only a few days they
originally didn't contain preservatives
but they were a cake with fresh whole
ingredients
but the cake couldn't be stocked on the
shelves like it is today Bill Clinton
loves Twinkies anytime you say Bill
Clinton loves it's a problem yeah that's
a red flag that's up there with Trump
loves I mean it's just you got a problem
going on here Bill Bill Clinton probably
loves the Twinkies that have the low
shelf life
ah the fresh young yeah
but here's the thing though like
look
this is a this is a thing I come back to
on this this show sometimes and I argue
it would sell and I'll argue it now
there's something to be said about the I
get that the preservatives are bad I
understand that preservatives are bad I
understand that fake food is a bad thing
and I'm talking about it now with like
the you know or earlier with the diet
I'm trying to do
and try to eat less fake stuff oh but
what about the
food uh
uh point is is there's something to be
said about the consistency of a fake
food there's something to be said about
for instance oh you know over at Auntie
hens licorice shop she makes it from
scratch every day
you're pulling out of your ass the worst
but she makes it fresh
exactly that's my point but I could go
get Twizzlers and you're like Twizzlers
always taste like Twizzlers and when you
want Twizzlers that's what it tastes
like so my point is with Twinkies first
of all I don't know a cake that emulates
what the twinkie is I've never had a
cake quite with those flavors okay we'll
give you that it's very unique and in
that shape and all that stuff but you
think that's big Twinkie that won't let
people but here's my here's go into that
but well here's my point is that
you can go to any one of a hundred bake
shops
and get something that you go well this
was made from scratch and you know what
it's a dice roll it's 50 50. it's either
going to be really good or it's going to
suck and also too you're like that that
says something to me it's like it's like
no when I can go to that aisle get the
twinkie and I go that's what I'm getting
this is why I argued Pro McDonald's
against Wendy's as the greatest fast
food chain I was like McDonald's is
creating a thing that I cannot emulate
any way any shape any form I can't get
it anywhere else when you want that
flavor you get that flavor and you get
it at one place in one place only
Wendy's I could make it at home if I
wanted to I could come pretty close to
Wendy's if I wanted to you you know
trial and error you could do it Twinkie
never ever ever that's true so you love
The Branding you love you love the ethos
of twinkie yeah now it's great branding
yeah that that the twinkie with the legs
and arms too yeah let's not forget that
it's a great mask
well it's like I like that it has skinny
arms and legs because that's probably
what your body would
[Laughter]
that tube with legs
I'm already a kid
but here's the thing you defended this
this Hostess cupcake which I think is an
Abomination I don't like the cupcakes
either yeah I mean if you want to talk
cupcakes go get a real cupcake I just
every time I've had a cupcake lately
they're dry and yeah but too much icing
that's true at the bakery they will let
them sit there yeah I need it I like my
cupcakes within minutes I did it was
when I did the 21 Day Sugar Detox I
never before this had any like Concept
in my mind of the taste of preservatives
and after this was during the pandemic I
didn't eat sugar for like a full month
and then ever since then all the
packaged like stuff at the store it
tastes like preservatives to me but
fresh stuff I like it so I think this
like before and after like kind of like
this was life-changing for me that I was
like oh now I can taste this tastes
preservatives taste a certain way to me
and fresh stuff I like it better
well yes I I I can't argue
that there's a value to to Fresh Foods
and few ingredient foods and things that
aren't loaded with chemicals and
preservatives I I could never argue that
that's an insane thing to argue right
but I don't think that's what we're well
maybe we are I was gonna say I don't
think that's what we're necessarily are
yeah
before I couldn't taste it like before I
did this I would be like Twinkies like
great love it I'll have it as a dessert
and now I'm like I'd actually just
rather kind of rather have nothing or
have like a piece of chocolate or
something I think if you took this was
this is what I would argue I think if
you took just like with McNuggets with
the microplastics if that microscope
isn't there you don't know it's there so
I would argue that if you had Twinkies
your entire life and nobody ever said do
you know what's in that you would be
like this tastes great it's when people
start to tell you this is in it that you
start to think about what's in it and
then suddenly you're like just tastes
weird Twinkies to me
now I might get a Twinkie on the way
home today how often do you because I
haven't had one in years I can't
remember the last time I had one yeah I
haven't had one in at least a year but
that's why I wanted just to see if I
really that's what I'm saying just to be
like do I hate this or do I love it this
is my favorite
if I eat a Pop-Tart which I've had
Pop-Tarts
I [ __ ] love pop and I like the
saltiness of the pastry that's why I
like it sugar
Twinkie oh yes it's a different thing
but my point is with Pop-Tarts that's
got all kinds of [ __ ] in it too it's
true it doesn't taste that way to me I
feel like if I ate a Twinkie right now
this is where I want to test it on the
way home also I'm craving it now but my
point is is
yeah if I feel like if I ate that right
now I wouldn't be like I taste
preservatives
like I'm trying to think of a food where
like I mean even a Slim Jim
which is clearly not a real food
it doesn't taste like preservatives to
me
what which what it triggers in my brain
is meat flavors yeah but but but it
triggers it triggers another part of my
brain that goes bro this isn't real food
and then that starts you then focusing
on why it's not real food yes and then
that starts you thinking about all the
fake [ __ ] in it and then and then you go
this is tastes like this and it's like
it doesn't taste like any of that it
tastes like meat it's just you know it's
not real meat so then that's all you're
going to think about I think you're I do
agree with this there's a psychosomatic
element because as I told Sarah this I
had to tripe recently which I thought
was fish do you know what tripe is
stomach yes I thought it was fish and I
thought I was having like this is when I
was in Rome I was like I'm having a
local fish but it was delicious it was
fine until I found out what it was and
then it tasted like stomach acid to me
and I couldn't finish it
we were saying that about I don't think
at least stomach it's sweetbreads is
tripe right in the same kind of vein I
don't know if it's exactly the same
thing I think it's like kidneys or
monkey bread is it intestine is tripe
intestine it's the stomach of the cow
that's used for the that the milk is
made in but we've talked about this with
like don't ever tell anyone that there's
anchovy paste and Caesar dressing
because all of a sudden they'll be like
ah gross and you're like you were eating
it all along and you liked it same thing
with tomato sauce sometimes I put
anchovy paste in my tomato sauce
no one can taste it but it adds a flavor
to it but it does not taste like and
it's like a Umami flavor but if I told
certain people oh I cooked anchovy paste
in here they would flip the table Yeah
they would use Sean Donnelly
I use anchovies I use fresh anchovies
sometimes when I make
um broccolini oh yummy I'll I'll mash up
an anchovy in the oil and with some
other stuff and it it gives a nice
flavor to it and if you never knew it
was anchovy you would just go this is a
a really interesting that's an
interesting you know gardettos have
anchovy flavoring to it right people
don't know that oh I love those but I
think people would like there was a
Funny Farm the movie funny farm with
Chevy Chase yes I never saw it it's a
it's a pretty funny movie but like um
there's uh the the most famous scene in
it is like he's eating balls yeah he
breaks the record for the mountain
oysters and he loves them
guys like I ain't never seen somebody
eats you know whatever yeah and he spits
them out and gets like sick and that's
the joke it's like yeah but until you
know I've had Mountain Oysters yeah they
taste fine they taste kind of like liver
but like you I already knew what they
were and I couldn't you can't get it out
of your head yeah yeah get it out of
your head the whole time it's like food
racism
futism
um but I would say the Twinkie
all in all I mean here's the other
reason we didn't put this to a vote
um as Sal pointed out it's going to be
90 yay to ten percent we're gonna get
some heat for our just like we are not
afraid to take a strong stance
I always lose on the show
uh I take the stand of the people
who go to Bakery where we're like I
can't I can't do sugar anymore
transcended to a higher after my yoga
retreat I just haven't been able to do
preservatives let me ask you this let me
ask you this by the way side note and
then but I want to ask you a question
about desserts in the twinkie but side
note the reason I'm not excited about
these McDonald's Happy Meals for
grown-ups
it's a replication of the cardboard box
Happy Meals which
are cool but they're too big in my
opinion because they have to house
bigger food for grown-ups
and there's nothing fun about it you
just open it and your meals inside of it
yeah and like you're still divorced yeah
and you're eating it in your car and
this toy with the four eyes looks like
something out of the goddamn folklore or
box set I just bought like it's freaking
me out I think they should actually do
adult toys in there yeah like a little
pepper spray or like weed pipes oh yeah
oh is it vibrators
I'm not kidding I just bought a box out
of full car called all the haunts br's
put out by Severin films if you like
horror and you like folk art check it
out it's an amazing box set but I
watched a movie last night from Russia
called V and one of the awful things he
sees in the movie it looks like those
goddamn fluoride uh uh Happy Meal toys
it's horrifying uh yeah this is I like
that I like sexy Ronald McDonald with a
cube fries I know it's like ooh fun
people keep sending me this I've gotten
this a million times I've gotten the
Grimace butt plug a million times thank
you I'm not complaining I appreciate the
love but uh I I can't buy any of this
this is like I don't know if you ever
read the book Wicked that the Bro the
Broadway show is based on it but the
Broadway show is very sterilized and
it's for families the book is really for
adults and like in the book The Witch
has sex and all this stuff you're like
oh don't do this to my Wizard of Oz it's
too much yeah I don't like this with my
Ronald McDonald it's gross yeah man he's
on his way to see Bill Clinton it's fan
fiction
sexual fan fiction yeah stop sexualizing
stuff I wanna I wanna ask this about
Twinkies to you to both of you um this
is my least favorite desserts on planet
Earth okay as we talk about things that
are sort of fabricated or concocted or
whatever word you want to put on it
when I go to a diner I love diners I
love Diner desserts but when I go to a
diner it's usually in diners I see this
and I see
the cakes with the plastic dividers
between the slices and and like for
instance like that strawberry cheesecake
that has that giant that like gleaming
red
strawberry jelly on top I I get so mad
because I'm like that came from a
factory that's not real that's not what
strawberry cheesecake looks like yeah
like like I get so upset at that like
because I'm like
I feel like those to me always taste
like the fakest desserts on plant like
I'd rather eat I'd rather just go buy a
[ __ ] Twinkie yeah like I'm like you
know or or if or uh whatever a processed
whatever from 7-Eleven I'm like again
because I know what I'm getting
I hate those two but I also have a food
aversion to like red like certain red
gelatinous foods from my childhood from
being sick so like I would never get
that I I can't even like it's NyQuil
look at somebody eating it yeah it's
like a cherry medicine
yes I agree the NyQuil thing's a good
point like and I I I agree it's a
childhood thing when I was a kid
every cough syrup was bright red yeah or
like Chinese so sick yeah yeah that
stuff is good
A little yeah everything everything was
bright red uh for medicine so I agree
Sucrets yeah which actually tastes
pretty good cherry flavored so but a lot
of Diner cakes I will say like I've had
bad experiences I love carrot cake
that's one of my number one cake that's
the only Diner cake I really can enjoy
or a cheesecake I don't mind for some
reason it's like I've never tried
cheesecake yeah the plastic dividers
though are really a red flag but I love
like a diner pie though I think that's
the way to go Diner pie where you know
that they made it there or a cobbler
because those aren't everything is
suspect once I see the plastic sleeves
everything in the diner is suspect now
yeah you had a good meal at a diner in a
while I have not it's always I'm just
like that was okay for 25 yeah I had to
mortgage my home my parents live in
Southampton New Jersey
which South Jersey is like the the land
of milk and honey for diners okay
they've got it they've got I'm not
kidding I think they have five diners
within a 15-minute radius I love it
you can get all kinds of [ __ ] at every
Diner there and it's pretty awesome one
of their diners Vincentown Diner which
is near where they live was on Diners
Drive-Ins and Dives oh that's cool but
like they but like so yes I have but I
hear you like it's going the way of the
dodo like New York diners these days
leave a lot to be desired
you've also always felt that New York
diners were underwhelming Manhattan for
all its glory and all its food diners
for some reason get a real it's like
sandwich shops that's why we opened a
sandwich shop it's like it's Corner
delis it's all very cookie Cuttery yeah
I don't know why that is you know though
I've only had one decent dining Diner
experience in New York and I can't even
remember that restaurant but I it's on
the upper west but I don't even think
it's there anymore
I used to go to a good diner in Cobble
Hill Diner when I lived in Brooklyn that
one was pretty good it was like classic
Greek diet or avalimono like everything
was fresh but but yeah especially in
Manhattan it's like you're going to
Orion Diner you're like I'm gonna pay 45
like why don't I just go eat Indian food
or something you know it's not like I
used to rent Bill Burr's apartment from
him
and uh there was a dying I can't
remember the name of it but there was a
diner in that neighborhood
and uh he I just remember him texting me
one he he had come back in from LA and
he was staying with me when I was
renting the apartment
and he texted me and the texture said
such and such Diner how many times do I
have to learn that lesson
I've gone back over and over and it
always sucks one rude is service yeah
it's so weird well like there's one in
Astoria every time we go in there the
ladies got like her foot off her shoe
and she's just kind of like spanning it
and then she just tells you to come in
how was that Diner
same as all of them yeah it's the same
as all of them I mean that one at least
I think the food is pretty good it's
like wildly overpriced you know yeah I
just stick to breakfast just go to like
a fancy burger place then where it's
gonna be like really good food if you're
gonna pay like twenty dollars
I I I I wanna I wanna close out with the
closing statement on The Twinkie okay I
think for your compact dessert needs
nothing will ever top it it's as compact
as easy and delicious As It Gets
I want you both to name your version of
that since you don't like the twinkie if
you're not going for Twinkie and you got
to go compact not messy
pop art Pop Tart Pop Tart yeah
I honestly like a the raspberry and I
don't even need icing on the top and I
don't even need it toasted I love where
your head's at yeah I I never toast them
I want to be a [ __ ] and say but the
Whole Foods has these brown butter
chocolate chip cookies they come in a
single serving you get it at the front
it is so good it's so satisfying all
right that's I have to say that yeah all
right
I love it you heard it here Whole Foods
has cookie
folks that is our show thank you both
for being here uh we don't have to do
any chance we don't have to do any polls
any plugs you guys have yeah please oh
yeah uh watch lady Journey podcast we
talk about baked goods yes please check
out our podcast lady Journey we talk
about travel stories lifestyle and a lot
of food and cooking stuff too and you
guys do cool short films too right
um how regular those right didn't you
just two one well we do those those are
unrelated to our broadcast yeah with
Sarah's husband
those are in our other departments but
please check out our podcast lady
Journey we love it and we think it's
really hilarious and fun and we do man
Journeys on there too we had Sean
Donnelly on there talking about upscale
menswear sweatshirt and we want Joe
Rogan because we do believe he goes on
lady Journeys with his sauna we are
going after getting him as a guest and
now we're just putting it out there
um we will be contacting him through his
website
oh come on I I'll come on time with my
facial routine oh I love
I love it uh
they're a stand-up too they're both
really hilarious I love these two
they're great uh thank you both for
being here uh and guys we'll we'll guys
and gals uh we'll see you next time on
taste buds taste buds they come into the
mic talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
Fool's gonna fight but only one food can
be right